الطائره الثانيه المتجهه الى مطار حلب
والمغادره من مطار الملك خالد الدولي في
العاصمه السعوديه الرياض وهي تعتبر
الطائره التاسعه ضمن الجسر الجوي السعودي
لدعم المتضررين جراء هذا الزلزال اما الان
ننتقل ونواكب ايضا الطائره العاشره ولكن
التي سوف تتجه الى مطار عنتاب داخل
الاراضي التركيه وتحمل على متنها قرابه
التسعينات طن من المواد الغذائيه وكذلك
الخيام
الغذائيه طبعا الطائره مختلفه وهي من طراز
بوينج 777 سوف تحمل كما ذكرت الاحتياجات
التي رفعها ممثلين مركز الملك سلمان
للاغاثه والاعمال الانسانيه من خلال
السلاله الغذائيه والخيام وكذلك ايضا بعض
المحاليل الطبيه وكذلك ايضا بعض
المستلزمات الطبيه ولكن لعل هذه الشحنه
تحديدا وهي الشحنه العاشره التي سوف تغادر
الى داخل الاراضي التركيه سوف تكون محمله
بشكل اكبر واكثر من
المستلزمات الايوائيه وكذلك السلال
الغذائيه وهي من ضمن الاحتياجات التي
رفعها ممثلي مركز مركز الملك سلمان لغاثه
والاعمال الانسانيه خاصه الان بعد انقاذ
العديد من من المدنيين جراء هذا الزلزال
هم الان بلا ماوى وهم يحتاجون الى الغذاء
يحتاجون الى الخيام يحتاجون ايضا الى
الحقائب
المكمله بالاواني الخاصه بهم ايضا سوف
تكون وسوف ترافق هذه الشحنه عدد من مقرات
الماوى الذي
تركيبها بشكل سريع وبشكل سهل حتى يتم اخذ
اكبر مساحه واكبر عدد ممكن من المتضررين
الذين تم انقاذهم سواء عبر الجهات
الحكوميه التركيه وكذلك بمساعده فرق البحث
والانقاذ السعودي الذي غادر الاسبوع
الماضي عبر وسائل ويحمل او كان برفقته
اليات وتقنيات تساعد في عمليات البحث
والانقاذ وكذلك وسائل حيه تساعد ايضا على
الكشف على من هم تحت الركام